hello everyone welcome to the biggest
ideas in the universe I'm your host Sean
Carroll we're on our fourth idea already
plenty more ideas in the future it does
strike me as I'm making these for those
of you future people watching recording
these during the coronavirus lockdown
and it was about time for me to get a
haircut just before the lockdown started
and there's no prospects of haircuts
anywhere in the immediate future
Jennifer my wife and I both had various
skills cutting hair is not among them so
it could be kind of an adventure going
forward with more and more ideas and
more and more length of the hair but we
all have to make our little sacrifices
anyway today our fourth idea is space I
don't mean space the final frontier or
outer space anything like that I mean
the three-dimensional space in which we
live this is clearly a big idea the
question is to what extent is an
interesting idea in the sense is there
anything to say about it I mean there's
a there's a point of view about space
which just says it's a primitive thing
that's where we live right there's no
choice about it philosophers argue over
whether Immanuel Kant thought that
three-dimensional Euclidean space was
somehow a priori like it couldn't have
been any other way there's there's no
way that we could have the sensory
capabilities and the vision the the
ability to sort of envision the world
the way we do if we didn't live in
three-dimensional Euclidean space
Euclidean in this case means something
that constant even know that it meant
the geometry of space itself and of
course Einstein came along to say that
the geometry of space is not Euclidean
space as part of space-time it can be
curved etc so whatever it is we don't
these days think of space as just
inevitable okay we can ask why space has
the properties it does a lot of these
questions going to happen within the
context of quantum mechanics and quantum
gravity we're not there yet we're not
being perfectly historical but still in
this particular video we're mostly
working in the context of classical
physics maybe 100 percent in classical
physics and I'm going to talk a little
bit about some features of general
relativity although it's
the main we haven't talked about general
relativity yet that's a future video so
we're not gonna be diving into it too
deeply okay what I do want to talk about
is well what is the most important
feature that you first notice about
space you know space like I said is the
place we live the set of points that you
would use to locate somebody okay the
set of possible positions that a point
could have that's what we mean by space
and the first thing we know about space
is that it is three-dimensional
okay what do we mean by that well the
dimensions are up down left right
forward backward how do we know that
space is three-dimensional how certain
are we of this so experimentally I'm not
going to do the experiment to draw the
experiment on the on the iPad here
experimentally here's something we can
do we can imagine a line so you know you
imagine holding up a stick and it's
there's no difficulty in taking another
line and drawing it at 40 at rather a
right angle perpendicular okay to the
first line I'm doing this on a
two-dimensional surface so let's think
about this two-dimensional surface
before we move to three-dimensional
space no problem in taking two lines and
putting them perpendicular to each other
in space but here on the surface or I'm
drawing that's it that's all you can do
there's no way for me to draw another
line a third straight line that is
perpendicular to both of these two at
the same time the maximum number of
perpendicular lines that I can draw on
this two-dimensional surface is two that
is why it is a two-dimensional surface
because there are only two directions
where a direction is defined as a
perpendicular way that you could
potentially move now in space if I'm not
just on the iPad but if I'm living in
the room here there's another direction
I can draw which we typically draw in
pictures as sort of at an angle but of
course it's a cheat a little bit okay
it's not truly on the on the board it's
not perpendicular but we are imagining
that we're here in space where I could
hold up a stick in one dimension hold up
another stick perpendicular to it and
hold up a third stick perpendicular to
both of those so voila space in which
live is three-dimensional try as you
will in the space than which we live you
cannot take four sticks hold them up in
a way that each one of them is
perpendicular to all the other three so
space is not four-dimensional it's
three-dimensional that's it that's why
space is three-dimensional that's why we
know space is three-dimensional but why
is space three-dimensional I mean why is
it like that why are there three
dimensions rather than some other number
so if we were if we were being
historically accurate and sort of what
are we talking about last time like
force and action and things like that
we're still kind of stuck in the 1800s
at best there's not that much you could
have said about why space was
three-dimensional well what else could
it have been maybe you could have said
but there were no dynamics there was no
way of saying well had it been something
else it would have evolved into three
dimensions or anything like that these
days we know a little bit more right and
we're skipping ahead historically to
point out that when Einstein does come
along and in 1915 he invents the general
theory of relativity he not only says
that space is part of space-time which
is four dimensional not just three
dimensional but he also says that it has
a life of its own that space can change
that there's a geometry to space that
need not be the geometry of Euclid where
initially parallel lines stay parallel
forever space timbi warp Zdenek and uh
change and be curved in various ways and
you and I experience the curvature of
space-time as gravity and almost as soon
as Einstein came up with this idea
people said well that's interesting that
means that I can change the
dimensionality of space and so let me
just explain a little bit about what
that means
imagine that you you had two dimensional
universe okay two dimensional space so
just because it's easier to draw not
because it's actually conceptually more
important that can be better if I could
draw more dimensions but imagine that
space was two dimensional but imagine
that it was wrapped up into a cylinder
rather than being an infinitely big
plane okay so here's a cylinder and
imagine it goes on forever in these
directions and this is two dimensional
space
so this is a hypothetical universe in
which we certainly don't live but
actually let me move this we use the
magic of computers to move this a little
bit good and then we can imagine two
different kinds of beings that could
live in this universe okay
one kind of being is really tiny it's a
little tiny person here this little tiny
person here says yeah space is two
dimensional I can move up and down like
a move right and left and I could even
if I'm very fast I could go around the
universe and come back to where I
started good for me but there's another
kind of being that is harder to draw
here but conceptually let me imagine a
being that is sort of I'm going to draw
them sideways but a being that is much
bigger in length oops
much bigger in length than the size of
this circle okay so here they are and to
this person you know the size of the
circle the size of one of their
dimensions of space is just really tiny
it's just maybe invisibly small from the
point of view of someone who is very
very big compared to this tiny little
dimension of space to them this space
looks one dimensional in other words
that he took this one this
two-dimensional cylinder and looked at
it from very far away it would look like
this right and that almost begins to
look like a one-dimensional line so it
turns out there's a whole longer spiel
here but if you imagine the world is
made of fields which we'll get to in
later videos and you have quantum
mechanics etc to access a really really
tiny dimension of space requires
incredibly high energies it becomes if
there's a relationship in quantum
mechanics between distance and energy
that things that are vibrating over very
very short distances have a lot of
energy just to make this little more
intuitive you might have heard that blue
wavelengths of light that are shorter
have higher energy photons associated
with them than red wavelengths of light
that are longer smaller wavelengths are
associated with higher energies so
smaller distances around a certain
direction of space are is also
associated with higher energies so the
point of this this is called Colusa
Cline theory after Ted or Colusa and
Oskar Klein who said to themselves again
almost right after Einstein came along
with general relativity they said well
maybe you could imagine that there are
tiny dimensions of space that because of
the rules of general relativity stay
tiny and therefore stay invisible to us
this is an incredibly cool idea and in
fact it's even better than it sounds
because Colusa inclined pointed out that
you could even try to explain the force
of electromagnetism doing this extra
one-dimensional circle of space and
that's a story we can't get into right
now but that was the initial motivation
that maybe you could unify gravity and
electromagnetism by adding an extra
dimension of space and then just making
it really tiny and curled up so you may
have heard that string theorists and
other people in modern physics have
taken this idea very seriously and the
string theory needs extra dimensions of
space strings naturally live in a 10
dimensional space-time so nine
dimensional space so they have to curl
up six dimensions of space somehow
there's extra complications because life
is complicated string theory has a
version of itself that is an 11
dimensional space-time rather than a 10
dimensional space-time but the point is
one way or the other you need these
extra dimensions of space so an enormous
amount of effort in modern physics has
gone into thinking about ways in which
extra dimensions of space could exist
but be curled up nothing to talk about
those in great detail today what I want
to do instead is say something that
actually has not received a lot of
attention why are some of the dimensions
small if they are or said the other way
why are three of the dimensions big so
that's the question that I would like to
talk about a little bit why three
macroscopic big dimensions and this is
something again that can only be talked
about in modern physics where you have
dynamical space-time etc but still it
gives you the reason why I'm doing this
is not so much to tell you what the
right answer is knowing it has any idea
what the right answer to this question
is but to let you know that it's a
question right to let you know there are
scientific theories that potentially
give answers to this particular question
so let me give you one particular
scientific theory this is called string
gas cosmology again we're way ahead of
the history here that's okay and the
first paper I know about this is from
Robert Brandenburger and Qumran Vava and
they made the following cute observation
let's imagine you did have more
dimensions of space let's imagine you
had nine dimensions of space like string
theory says might be the case and let's
imagine that they're all small for some
reason so this is the miracle this is
like the you know you're allowed one
miracle and your scientific theory it's
not just kidding you know your lads zero
miracles in your scientific theory but
you're allowed one posit okay like let's
imagine that so let's imagine that the
universe used to be very small so
imagine that all the dimensions are tiny
and I'm gonna draw them as a cube why am
I gonna do that well because really what
I want to draw is a torus a torus looks
something like this right it looks like
the external surface of a doughnut it's
a two-dimensional surface that you can
go around in one of two different
directions but another way of drawing
this torus which I just drew would be to
draw a square but identify the opposite
sides so the point of this picture is to
say if I were a little person living on
this square with opposite sides if I
walked upward in this direction I would
then come out here so it's like a video
game like it if your my my era it would
be asteroids where you fly on one side
of the video screen you come out the
other that is secretly a tortoise if you
take this square you wrap it up it
becomes a torus you wrap it up in both
dimensions we're imagining that whatever
it is you're wrapping has infinite
flexibilities or nothing rips
tears or anything like that so what I
want to draw is a three-dimensional
torus so what I'm going to draw is a
cube and then I'm going to ask you to
imagine that the different sides of the
cube are identified okay so if I walk
into one edge of the cube I come back
into the other edge so this is a
three-dimensional torus and what I'm
really imagining is a nine dimensional
torus but I cannot draw a nine
dimensional tourist so imagine is
three-dimensional torus and imagine that
the world is described by string theory
okay like brain and burger and buffa
imagined so what you say is if you zoom
in a little bit so there's gonna be
little loops of string this is what
string theory says loops of string
you're gonna be moving around inside the
torus I'm not explaining all string
theory now but you've heard probably
that the basic positive string theory is
that instead of particles the world is
made of strings that's all you need to
know for this this particular
demonstration what Brandenburger i'm
fafa point out is that in addition since
this whole thing is very very tiny in
addition to the idea that a string can
float around inside the dimensions
strings can also wrap around the whole
universe very easily so since the top of
this cube is identified with the bottom
this thing that are just true this
vertical line is a loop of string that
is wrapped around one dimension of the
universe and this can happen in any of
the dimensions of the universe so we can
have another string wrapped around this
way not the best drawing there but you
know what I mean well let me try to do
it better try to get away from the extra
parts of my cube here okay there you go
so there are different ways the strings
can wrap around they can wrap around any
one of the nine different dimensions of
space but if you have and this is the
part that's hard to visualize but but
you you probably can get it if space
were four dimensional two strings would
just generically pass right by each
other
okay there's even though you think like
two one-dimensional things would
generically hit each other that's
because you live in three-dimensional
space
if you imagine two points on a line two
points will always hit each other in
two-dimensional space they will
generically move by likewise strings
generically move by each other if space
is four-dimensional but not if it is
three-dimensional so what can happen
here is that if these strings are sort
of wound around these compact dimensions
of space and the tension in the strings
is part of what is contributing to
keeping the cubes small keeping the
torus at a fixed size then in three
dimensions these strings let's see if I
can do this let's see if I can do some
magic here move it over copy it paste it
look at that oh my goodness of getting
good at this okay what can happen is
this original situation where there's
strings wrapping in different directions
these strings are going to hit each
other in some three dimensional subspace
of the nine dimensional cube in a four
dimensional subspace they will just pass
right by but in the three dimensional
part of it they can hit each other and
when they hit each other what will
happen is this initial situation will
change because the strings can reconnect
in a certain way so that it looks like
this okay see what happened there the
strings were originally just
individually crossing but now they can
reconnect and now they can just unwind
so what can happen is this string is now
not wrapped around the different
dimensions of space it can just shrink
to zero so what happens then according
to Brandenburger and fafa is that this
cube can just start growing it can get
bigger and bigger and bigger
very sloppy cube there sorry about that
but you get the point in some
three-dimensional subspace of the whole
nine dimensional compact torus
brandenberger Bafa say strings can
originally be wrapped around and holding
it together but they can keep hitting
each other
unwinding and those three dimensions can
begin to grow so in other words
brandenberger Bafa are both suggesting a
scenario
for how the universe might have started
right originally a tiny little tourist
that was compact and stationary but then
it unwound a little bit and also
explaining why only three dimensions of
space are big because if the world is
made of strings three dimensions are the
number of dimensions that generically
strings can unwind in and let those
three dimensions expand now I'm not a
big fan actually this particular
scenario I loved it when I first heard
it I was a graduate student this came
along I thought it was like genius
because at least they're trying right to
explain the three dimensions of space
these days we know that string theory is
not just a theory of strings in addition
to strings there are things like
two-dimensional brains and
three-dimensional brains brain being a
brain oops
B or a and E comes from the word
membrane and it's just a way of saying a
surface or an object that is more than
two-dimensional so a membrane is
two-dimensional three brains are
three-dimensional etc so there's
actually lots of different ways to wrap
strings and brains around initially tiny
compact manifolds and the tiny compact
space doesn't have to be a torus it can
be something more complicated
so the initial charm of thinking that
you have explained why space is
3-dimensional maybe has gone down a
little bit when we appreciate the more
of the complexity of string theory but
still again it's an attempt right you
know maybe something like this is
actually explaining why space is
three-dimensional so that's a good thing
to imagine being doing I want to explain
tunneling let me let me say it this way
I would like to explain going for making
dimensions disappear that's the right
way of saying it so the one of the
posits of the Brandenburg of alpha model
or was that dimensions
if you wanted to ask why did the
universe originally start pining
they say well we know it did so let's
just say that it did and they don't try
to explain that part of it maybe the
universe didn't start tiny like we're
prejudiced a little bit or at least we
are oriented toward the fact that our
universe is expanding and therefore it
was smaller and therefore it seems
natural for us to imagine the universe
starting as something small but we
should be more open-minded about that
maybe it didn't is there any way of
imagining that there were more than
three big dimensions of space and the
dimensions somehow disappear so there is
a way and this way this actually comes
from a paper that I helped write so this
is me Matt Johnson and Lisa Randall and
we suggest we point out the following
thing and we borrowed from a lot of
other people as always happens in
physics right but imagine that you have
again a two dimensional plane imagine
this goes out infinitely far so we're
not cheating by already having it be
wound up you might say well I want to
make a dimension disappear so the
natural thing to imagine is that somehow
one of these dimensions just curls up so
this becomes that kind of cylinder that
we talked about before right but that
seems you know essentially infinitely
unlikely because if this initial plane
is infinitely big in all directions how
in the world can it curl up an infinite
amount of space in one direction to
become some finite size circle that
seems unlikely and presumably this is
why people have not traditionally looked
at the idea of making dimensions
disappear but there is another way to do
it again in string theory although it's
not a very stringy construction you can
do it without the details of string
theory and the way to do it is to not
wrap up all of the universe but you dig
a hole in space you're not really doing
that but metaphorically that's what
you're doing in other words extending a
region of space down into a cylindrical
kind of configuration and this goes
infinitely far down so in some region if
you just stretch
space you kind of imagine pulling it and
you pull it infinitely far but it
doesn't keep getting smaller and smaller
as you pull rather it stabilizes at some
fixed size if you imagine just looking
at I'm actually gonna invoke suggestion
that was made in the questions to other
videos which is rather than me pointing
at my pad that you folks can't see I
should just use another color so okay so
if you imagine just looking at this part
of the space right well it looks just
like a cylinder it looks just like the
cylinder on the other side right if you
ignore the fact that it's connected to
this wider universe then this part right
here that part right there looks like a
cylinder so it looks like there's one
dimension that is really long and
another dimension that is all curled up
both of these dimensions stand in for
many more dimensions than that that I
can't draw okay
so rather than really imagining that you
start with a two dimensional space and
dynamically compacta fiying it as we say
down to a one dimensional space plus a
tiny circle we can imagine starting with
a what do we start with a five
dimensional space and then we
dynamically compactify it down into a
big three dimensional space plus a tiny
little two dimensional sphere so the
realistic scenario is 5d space goes into
3d space times it's mathematically this
is a product of two different manifolds
times a two dimensional little sphere s2
as we call it okay a two dimensional
sphere so well fine I mean I can say
these words right I can I can draw these
pictures does it actually happen yes it
can happen in fact we show very very
simple circumstances in which it must
happen in which quantum mechanics plus
gravity plus electromagnetism is all you
need you also need some cost module
constant or other things that we all all
things that we know we have we showed
that if you start in a six dimensional
space-time five dimensional space plus
one dimensional time this kind of
activation down to four dimensional
space time times tiny little circle is
inevitable inevitably going to happen
some places sometimes so of course you
are then welcome to ask well why in the
world did you ever start with a six
dimensional space-time five dimensions
of space that are all really big I have
no answer to that
that was not part of what we did so
again I'm not trying to give you the
final answer but I'm just pointing out
that you can get rid of or create big
dimensions of space both ways you can
both start small and make some
dimensions big you can start with
dimensions big you can make them
disappear effectively by compacta fiying
them into a tiny little ball that you
and I could not see so what this opens
up is the idea that maybe the fact that
space is three-dimensional is not just a
law of nature it's not just there once
and for all
okay it's not just inevitable it's just
not built-in it's not a priori maybe
it's something that dynamically happens
and then you might want to ask well okay
if that can happen then why don't we
live in a four dimensional space or five
dimensional or two dimensional or eight
dimensional or whatever that's another
good question right is there some
principle is there some reason why this
is bringing us back to the question we
started with why actually three
dimensions of space so I don't know the
answer this one either sorry you know
I'm just having fun by skipping ahead to
some of the more speculative stuff we're
gonna for the next few lectures we're
gonna do plenty of very well-established
things don't worry about that I
shouldn't call these lectures casual
chats about the biggest ideas in the
universe but we can have fun you know
we're not we're not teaching you a
course there's no quiz at the end of
this so why is it actually three
dimensions I have no idea there was an
interesting paper by Max tegmark max of
course is a well-known cosmologists and
writer max was a guest on my podcast
mindscape a few months ago when we
talked about the anthropic principle and
the multiverse and other ideas he's a
big fan of and so there was a paper
where he applied these ideas to the
dimensionality of space what he claimed
which I think is a little bit of an over
claim but I can explain why
what he claimed is that there is an
anthropic reason why even if you had
many different parts of reality where
the dimensionality of space was
different we would find ourselves in the
three-dimensional part so you've heard
of the anthropic idea which is that if
there are many different parts of the
universe where conditions are very very
different of course there's a selection
effect okay there's a selection bias
intelligent creatures are only going to
find themselves in those parts of the
universe where intelligent creatures can
come to be there you go so we can apply
that kind of reasoning and you know by
the way that kind of reasoning is a
hundred percent true I mean it's almost
trivial and tautological the only
controversial part is does there exist a
universe in which different regions have
very very different conditions like
different dimensionalities of space that
we have no idea about right but if there
are different regions where conditions
are very very different indeed there
will be a selection effect and we're
only gonna find ourselves in those
regions where we can exist duh I don't
see how you can even argue against that
so here's what here's what he says well
what if the dimensionality of space D
was less than 3 so let's go one by one
let's imagine that it was just
two-dimensional here's two-dimensional
space okay 2d space could we live in 2d
space and what max says is basically no
because it's too simple there's not
really a lot that can happen in
two-dimensional space so what does that
mean I mean basically what it means is
you know the famous idea is if you
wanted to have an animal okay here's
some blobby kind of animal and it has a
mouth and this mouth it eats things so
there's food food pellets come into the
mouth of little animal well it's gonna
need a digestive tract and it's gonna
need to expel that food at some point
and if this is really a mouth that you
can eat in oops
that's not right my eraser is not very
good here yeah okay can't do that let me
just draw the whole thing again
so basically what would have to look
like is it has a mouth and then you know
the top of the animal but the digestive
tract would literally split the animal
into two pieces and then they would just
fly away from each other you could not
have a digestive tract in two dimensions
and maybe that's kind of important to
you but you know maybe that's not
important to you right like why can't we
just have an animal that looks like this
that you know can eat something digest
it and spit it out using the same thing
I kind of by the intuition that says
two-dimensional space is a little bit
too simple to have complicated
intelligent life in it but I'm always
very very wary of reasoning from our
experience with questions like this of
course we live in a world where we have
three dimensions to take advantage of
and we do and it helps us be extremely
complex therefore it is hard for us to
imagine complex life arising in
two-dimensional space but the fact that
it's hard for us to imagine does not
mean it's impossible it's very hard to
imagine a proof that it's impossible but
I get that there's some logic to that
and if you went down from
two-dimensional space to one-dimensional
space it would even be worse so maybe
that's a good argument maybe it's not
maybe we just don't know enough right
now to say what about dimensions larger
than three you might think if there were
more than three dimensions of space then
we could be even more complicated right
if we can have complex life in 3d then
we could have even more in four
dimensions etc and maybe that's true but
but max points out another interesting
fact that is kind of well-known remember
we live on a planet that orbits the Sun
right and we already talked about
Kepler's laws and so there's a little
elliptical orbit Isaac Newton showed
that you could actually derive these
elliptical orbits from the inverse
square law for gravity this doesn't work
in three dimension in larger than three
dimensions of space you can have orbits
okay you can have a planet orbiting the
Sun in three dimensions but remember one
of Newton's insights was
other planets gently perturb you out of
your orbit right it's not just you and
the Sun moving around in the solar
system we also have to put her in Mars
and Venus and all those other things so
it is only in three dimensional of space
in only in three-dimensional space that
planetary orbits are stable so what
about dimensions greater than three
these orbits would be unstable what does
that mean it means that oops you have
some position you have some velocity or
some momentum okay what if you just and
you're going around in some orbit what
if you just tweak it a little bit what
if you have some force like another
planet that moves you away from your
orbit what would happen in dimensions
larger than three is that rather than
just being a slightly different orbit
you would either spiral into the center
or escape to infinity those are the
generic things that could happen that's
what it means for the orbits to be
unstable you could move in a perfect
circle but if your circle is not perfect
in four or five or six dimensions of
space then you could not orbit forever
and ever and ever
so maybe we think that for intelligent
life to arise you need something like
planets moving around stars in
long-lived orbits again you know I don't
know that you really need that I'm
pretty much wholly unconvinced by this
you know the the two-dimensional space
okay I get it it's it's hard for us to
be quite this simple but the four or
five dimensional space seems like the
complexity still has plenty of room to
exist even if the way that complex
structures would arise would be very
very different in this kind of world
than in ours so I'm not further we have
any reason yet to disbelieve on
anthropic grounds that we could have
lived in dimensions greater than three
another way of saying this whole
argument is the tying your shoelaces
argument exactly because we said three
dimensions are the number of dimensions
in which strings can hit each other
generically if you try to make a knot if
you try to literally tie a knot with a
one-dimensional string in four
dimensions of space there are no knots
that can instantly that cannot instantly
be undone okay
so if you're in two-dimensions you can't
tie a knot because the strings can't
cross each other in the first place
if you're in four dimensions they can
always just pass right through and they
can undo the knot
I have no intuition that tying your
shoelaces is really really important but
maybe that's the reason why we live in
three-dimensional space ok so again I'm
not here in this particular discussion
to give you the final answer I'm here to
say these are potentially answerable
questions and we should be thinking
about them now let's shift gears let's
shift gears rather dramatically here
what I was just trying to do was explain
how we can think about why space has
three dimensions now I want to think
about why is there space at all
why is space a thing and there there's
different angles you can take on this
question of course you know why is there
the universe why does anything exist
rather than any nothing this is a it's a
different set of questions what I really
mean by this is why does the stuff of
physics take the form of stuff living in
space why can we organize the world into
objects with locations okay that might
seem like so big a question that we
don't even know how to make the first
little progress in answering it but we
actually do there's there's a context in
which we can address this question quite
directly and what that context is is yet
another reformulations of classical
mechanics remember we said that there
was Newtonian mechanics and this was the
F equals MA way of doing things so you
have some particle or some object with a
position and a momentum and then you
chug forward in time and ask what it
does then we said that there is the
least action-y which was you take an
initial position and you take the final
position both with some fixed times and
you find the path in between them that
minimizes a certain thing called the
action so it's a more global versus
local point of view you might think of
those two options are all you get but
there is another way called the Hamilton
point of view so this is a way of
formulating classical mechanics it's not
a different theory it's yet another
reformulation of exactly the same theory
it seems at first glance like a needless
bit of formalism okay like you're taking
something you understand perfectly well
the Hamiltonian point of view is very
close to the newtonian point of view
it's not really like the least action
point of view although there's a
relationship there also it's still you
start with initial conditions and you
chug them forward in time but how you
phrase what the initial conditions are
is a little bit different and how you
get the equations of motion is a little
bit different it's not just that V
equals MA so it can at first glance seem
just like a needlessly abstract
mathematical reformulation but once you
get to higher-level physics concepts the
Hamiltonian perspective is the way to go
for instance in quantum mechanics the
Schrodinger equation realize completely
on the idea that you have a Hamiltonian
and that's how you formulate physics so
what is going on here remember that
phase space which was the space of
initial conditions or conditions at any
one time is that was the space of
positions X and momenta P okay and we
said that you could chunk forward in
time by saying that the velocity is let
me say it this way that the rate of
change of position is given by the
velocity which is given by momentum over
the mass and the rate of change of the
velocity over time is the acceleration
which is given by the force over the
mass this is the Newtonian way of
thinking about it so really in the
Newtonian way of thinking about it the
thing that exists if you have space here
X Y and this is time okay then you have
a trajectory X of T and that's what
matters X as a function of time is what
matters the velocity is derived from the
motion of X okay the Hamiltonian way is
different the Hamiltonian way says look
at this
structure that we have a phase space
here okay X and P put X and P on more of
an equal footing so rather than thinking
of the momentum is something that is
derived from position by taking the
velocity then multiplying by the mass P
equals MV this is the usual way of
thinking about it rather than doing that
say that the position and the velocity
are true or to truly independent things
okay
and construct from these independent
things a function of them a function of
space phase space called the Hamiltonian
in the Hamiltonian you know it's
basically the energy that's what it is
right so it's basically the energy but
it's the energy why saying basically is
because it's the energy as a function of
position and velocity position and
momentum
sorry position momentum that's the whole
point is that it's not a function of
position and velocity it's a function of
position and momentum so you know we
said that the energy equals sorry for
the math here but I think the concepts
are easy enough to follow energy is
kinetic plus potential and we had little
formulas kinetic energy is one-half mass
times velocity squared potential energy
is just some function V of X it only
depends on X not on the velocity or the
momentum so if velocity is momentum
divided by mass then this equals
one-half P squared divided by M right if
you plug in V equals P over V and the
potential is still just B of X so in
other words this energy this is now the
Hamiltonian it is a function of X and P
it equals one-half P squared over M plus
V of X see there's no velocities that
appear in there anymore just momentum P
and position X okay again it seems like
a kind of abstract nonsensical way of
rewriting things we already knew but
here's the point there there's a
conceptual issue that comes a
when people have first introduced to
this because if we go back to our
picture of space
here's XY and time I want to make that
look like why time is up here and we
have this trajectory going here you know
we say look if you have a point on the
trajectory where the particle is moving
with some velocity okay then how in the
world can the velocity be independent of
the position right it can't be the
velocity is derived from the position
that's all true in this picture that is
true but what I want you to try to
imagine is that we forgetting about the
velocity okay
we're imagining there's something called
the momentum and at every moment of time
let me just undo this and do the
complications of my picture at every
moment of time we have two things let's
in fact let's even get rid of the
trajectory okay we have the position X
and we have the momentum P so the
momentum is still a momentum but these
are two pieces of data that we're giving
you the location and the momentum and
then rather than saying the position is
defined the the momentum is defined to
be the mass times the velocity we say
there are now two equations of motion
there's one equation that replaces F
equals MA forces mass times acceleration
which says that the velocity the rate of
change of the momentum if you think
about that momentum was mass times
velocity the rate of change velocity
acceleration this is just MA which is
just the force that's an equation of
motion DP DT I'm gonna erase the part in
between equals F that's the replacement
for F equals MA there's another equation
of motion that says that the derivative
of position with respect to time which
is supposed to be velocity velocity was
P over m so it that's what it still is P
over m so you see these two equations
change of position with time is force
change of position sorry change of
momentum with time is force change of
position with time is momentum over mass
there's no mention of velocity here
these two equations are on an equal
footing and in fact you can derive these
two equations from this Hamiltonian
function I'm not going to try to tell
you how to do it but that's the point so
what do you imagine is just to start
from scratch imagine that instead of
drawing space here let me draw a phase
space so this is X and this is P and
there's some function on here okay
called the Hamiltonian which is a
function of X and P and by taking the
slope of the Hamiltonian in different
directions I can derive these two
equations of motion the equation for P
and the equation for x so in other words
yet other words when I am drawing this
picture of a trajectory through time and
I say look here's a trajectory through
time here's the velocity V how in the
world could the momentum possibly be not
in the same direction how in the world
could the momentum be a separate thing
the answer is the momentum is defined to
be a separate thing but on the actual
trajectory there will be a relationship
P equals MV just just like in ordinary
mechanics I have F equals MA I can solve
for the actual trajectory that the
particle takes but I can imagine other
trajectories I can imagine the particle
doing whatever it wants violating laws
of physics right the point is P equals
MV is not a definition it's a new law of
physics that you could imagine violating
you can imagine the momentum and the
velocity pointing in separate directions
but they don't in the real world that's
the Hamiltonian point of view okay so
the Hamiltonian point of view is you
start with this function of phase space
X and P you can derive these equations
and they are exactly the same as the
equations of Newtonian mechanics so why
am I telling you this right this is that
question will appear many many times in
these videos why am I telling you this
why are we bothering with all this
formalism well the
is because these equations and this
picture really do put P and X on kind of
an equal footing right they treat them
almost symmetrically there's little
details here but basically rather than P
being derived from the velocity and
therefore from the position it has a
life of its own there is a it's a
quantity all by itself there's the
location
there's the momentum these two
quantities go into defining the
Hamiltonian and from them we get the
laws of physics
so from that perspective we've undone
the idea that position is somehow prior
to momentum in Newton's way of thinking
about it where he worried to have
defined momentum he would just say well
yeah position over time is what matters
momentum comes from that here we're
saying that momentum matters all by
itself just as much as position does so
now we can ask well if that's true why
do we live in space why not living in
momentum space momentum space exists
again it's not
that's the mathematicians use of the
word space it is a space of possible
things phase space which equals the set
of all positions and momentum is is six
dimensional but space is only
three-dimensional why do we take this
three-dimensional part of phase space
that we call space and make it primary
why do we make it central why do we make
it the important thing it's not even a
question you would ask in good old
Newtonian way of thinking about things
it was the important thing we put that
in William Rowan Hamilton comes along he
invents the Hamiltonian way of looking
at things there's various senses which
we're not going to go into in which the
Hamiltonian way of looking at things is
more fun
mental more powerful and from that
perspective there's a new question you
would never have thought to ask why
don't we live in momentum space so we
don't fully know the answer to this but
we kind of know this is a situation
where we know the basic reason why
things are the certain way they are we
just have yet to work out all of the
details and here is the basic reason why
imagine that you have two billiard balls
moving toward each other in good old
Newtonian mechanics okay so they have a
position x1 x2 they have a momentum p1
p2 and if they're billiard balls so they
don't have you know forget about the
gravitational force of them or anything
like that
neither of these billiard balls will
know about the existence of the other
one or be affected by it until they hit
each other right until they smack into
each other in the middle in other words
they do not interact until they are at
the same point in space there is no
analogous question no no analogous
statement about momentum so if the two
billiard balls had the same momentum or
the opposite momentum but were pointed
in different directions or they would
never hit each other they don't interact
with each other there's no sense in
which having the same momentum or equal
but opposite momenta has anything to do
with whether you are interacting with
each other so the motto here is
interactions this is a simple example
but we can extend it and generalize it
are local in space real space the space
of all possible positions it's when
you're at the same position did you
interact with something not when you're
at the same momentum and even if you do
include gravity and things like that
we'll talk about this but it's still
true that you only interact when you're
at the same position in space so what
this suggests this is everyone knows
this this is not everyone knows this but
this is a well-known fact interactions
are local in space the locality okay in
physics but to answer our question why
do we live in space why not momentum
space
this fact that interactions are local in
space suggests an answer
space as opposed to momentum space or
phase space or anything like that the
space of all locations is the thing in
which interactions are local so in other
words if you started if someone handed
you a Hamiltonian as a function of
position momentum but they didn't tell
you which was position and which was
momentum okay you could figure it out if
this Hamiltonian was supposed to be you
know the game that you play in physics
when I say there's a Hamiltonian
function what I mean is you tell me the
physical system it's some billiard balls
or it's some planets with gravitational
fields or it's a spring or a pendulum or
whatever it is and then you can figure
out what the Hamiltonian of that system
is you know we wrote down this simple
thing kinetic energy plus potential
energy but you can generalize that
electromagnetism standard model of
particle physics whatever it is all of
these different systems have their own
Hamiltonian in fact they are defined by
their Hamiltonian once you tell me what
the objects are and what their
Hamiltonian is that defines the theory
so what I'm suggesting here is if
someone gave you a Hamiltonian but
disguised which parts of the phase space
were positions and which were momenta
you could figure it out
because you could look at that
Hamiltonian and say okay what are the
variables with respect to which
different parts of the system are
interacting locally when the variables
take on the same values and you would
call that space okay so there seems to
be some sense in which you can
understand why we live in space why not
momentum space there's still a question
why is there why are there any
dimensions with respect to which
interactions are local why is locality a
thing that I don't know you know that I
have no clues right now why is there
locality it's not because
it necessarily needed to be that way
if you imagine the space of all
hamiltonians the space of all theories
of physics most of them would not have
any notion of locality whatsoever it
does not seem to be generic there's
something special about the real laws of
physics that we have in our world that
has this feature of locality and as far
as I know no one's really sure why but
you should be inspired by the fact
earlier in the video where we talked
about even such a basic question as why
are there three dimensions of space
might be answerable in the right context
may be questions like this are
answerable to even though right now we
don't have an answer maybe some of you
have answers I don't know let me wrap
this up a little bit by saying you know
by going back to the billiard balls and
saying okay I said we ignore the
gravitational force right between these
two things because if I have two objects
you know let's ask about gravity I had
two objects that are far away from each
other object one object to some distance
R between them the force between them if
this is Capital m and this is little m
they've both exert the same force on
each other that's an R there just to be
clear which is Newton's constant times
mass 1 times mass 2 over R squared so
Big M pulls on little M little m pulls
on big M they're not at the same point
in space did I lie to you so Newton
worried about this right this is action
at a distance
he had this intuition that it makes
sense for billiard balls to bump into
each other when they're located the same
point in space and yet his law of
universal gravity seemed to say that
even when things were not at the same
point in space
they were still interacting with each
other and he worried about this he wrote
in the Principia Mathematica this is an
issue that he basically leaves for
future generations to solve he knew you
there's probably possible to do better
very often when physicists talk about
this they give credit for answering this
to Einstein Einstein came up with
general relativity last we said in 1915
and there there is a gravitational
field that is defined by the curvature
of space-time and there things are
perfectly local but in fact the answer
is already implicit in that sentence but
it way predates Einstein the answer is
there's a gravitational field we use
that language all the time you probably
use that language yourself the
gravitational field of the Sun pulls on
the earth okay so but there's a subtle
but crucially important thing going on
here
Newton's way of formulating it was there
just is a force acting on the earth just
because there exists the Sun 93 million
miles away okay there's nothing in
between the earth and the Sun it was our
old friend Laplace pierre-simon Laplace
as far as I know again the history is
not my thing but this is what I think it
was who said you could rewrite Newton's
law of gravity in terms of a
gravitational potential Phi as a
function of X don't ask me why they call
it Phi but that's what they often do and
so what what Laplace said is if we if we
plot fine it's usually a negative number
so there you go here is the distance
between let's say here's the Sun here's
the earth and Phi it's on the vertical
axis here looks like this and he amended
two equations one equation was what does
Phi do and the answer is when you have a
big massive object v pushes it down okay
that's why the Sun is pushing down Phi
down here at R equals zero the other
equation says if you're a little object
even if you're a big object if you're an
object that is in the midst of some Phi
if you're feeling the influence of some
Phi there is a force on you that is just
like the force we talked about for
potential energy before that's why it's
called the gravitational potential field
the force is minus the slope of the
potential
so the PLoS invents a set of equations
which says there is something in between
the Sun and the earth and that something
is the gravitational field the
gravitational potential field and I can
write down equations for it where
there's no action at a distance at all
right where the force the the influence
of the Sun on the field only happens
where the Sun is located and then the
field obeys its equation which tells
what that what is the field right there
it depends on what is the field right
next to it on one side and what right
next door on the other side and guess
what you use calculus to relate what the
field is doing at one point to
neighboring points but that's all that
it affects it all that the field at one
point cares about is what the field is
at immediately neighboring points
there's no influence very very far away
so the action at a distance has gone
away it's the it's field theory this is
the answer
why is there no action at distance the
answer is the world is made of fields or
at least at this point of the analysis
forces come from fields but we'll
eventually get to the point where we
just say the whole world is made of
fields that is the ultimate
manifestation the ultimate impact of
locality there is no action at a
distance now I should say this became
more complicated as many things did when
quantum mechanics came along we'll get
to that at some later point but if
you've heard the phrase action at a
distance you may have heard it in the
context of spooky action at a distance
and that appears in quantum mechanics so
in quantum mechanics the following thing
can happen I can have two particles that
are spinning so we will you know draw
this as one particle spinning that way
another particle spinning in the
opposite direction okay so we might call
this spin up spin down and we might draw
that in quantum mechanics that's just an
up arrow and a down arrow
two particles can be spinning in
opposite directions okay
what can happen quantum mechanically as
you probably know is that these
individual particles with their
individual spins might not be simply
spinning up or down but in some
superposition and some combination of
spinning up or spinning down until we
measure them and once we measure them
you can immediately you will only ever
get spin up or spin down not some
combination so these two particles in
quantum mechanics can be entangled with
each other the two particle state can be
a combination of both particles our spin
up and both particles our spin down in
other words you don't know the spin of
either one particle if you observe it
but when you observe it you instantly
know the spin of the other particle and
furthermore there's no reason at all for
these two particles to be near each
other so you can have one particle over
here and another particle over here and
let me draw this particle better okay so
we don't know the spin of either one of
these this is usually in the trade
Alice's particle and Bob's particle so
we know that both of these particles are
spinning in the same way in fact even if
you orient their spins to try to measure
them in some other axis other than
vertically if you measure them
horizontally or whatever you always know
they're spinning the same way and what
we don't know is what way that is so
when Alice measures her particle and she
says ah it's spinning up then Alice
instantly knows that Bob's particle is
also spinning up and if you believe that
the quantum state is real if it
describes the real world
then it seems that Bob's quantum state
changed instantly even though Alice is
very very far away so it seems like even
though Newton and Laplace and Einstein
had vanquished the idea of action at a
distance in favor of locality and the
importance of space and spatial location
quantum mechanics seems to be bringing
back the idea of action at a distance
and Einstein did not like that happily
you cannot use this kind of entanglement
in quantum mechanics to send signals
because
even though Alice now knows what Bob's
spin is Bob still doesn't know Bob has
learned nothing from this okay
unless Alice tells Bob by some good old
classical slower than light
communication device Bob's not able to
do anything with the fact that Alice
measured her spin so it seems like a
weird little loophole that the way that
we talk about what's happening involves
action at a distance but no
observational outcome is actually
influenced by it no information is
transmitted what are we going to do
about that we'll have to wait till
future lectures to do something about
that for for this one I just want to
emphasize that space has a meaning but
we're able were allowed were encouraged
to interrogate what that meaning is and
where it came from why is face
three-dimensional why is there space at
all might space be just emergent from
some deeper quantum description or
something like that we can talk about
that more we're allowed to talk about
that that's the good news
the other thing let me mention for those
of you who don't know we do have a QA if
you have questions leave them in the
YouTube or in the blog post I will try
to answer some of them clearly if we
want to go further in this direction we
need to talk about time so usually I'm
going to try to keep the next big idea
that we talk about secret but given that
we just talked about space next time
we'll talk about time